With so many amazing things happening in the world today,
what could possibly go wrong?
A giant asteroid is built on a collision course with earth and life.
As we know it is on the brink
after the smoke clears, how do we start over?
Where would we live and what might we do
differently? This is what if,
and here's what would happen if there were only 1000 people on earth,
pandemics, election scandals, civil unrest,
why maybe it's time for a duo over a clean slate,
a fresh beginning with only 1000 people left on the
planet. 500 women and 500 men. Where would we begin?
First of all, we'd need to work together to flourish,
rebuild society and repopulate the planet.
We'd need to farm hunt and help each other succeed.
Sounds like a pretty good starting point. Right? Okay.
Where would we find the ideal place to build this global village?
Most likely a temperate region.
That's not subject to huge threats from wildlife or natural disasters.
Let's stay away from the ring of fire because earthquakes would not help our
society to rebuild.
We don't want to live in an area where malaria is common either.
That's good living in the North like Canada,
especially Northern Canada would mean surviving, intense winters.
So no. How about Mediterranean Europe?
It's got a long growing season for food and there aren't as many natural
wildlife threats as there are in Africa or Australia.
Now that we found the perfect location,
let's start by meeting our basic survival needs like water, food,
shelter, and sleep.
We have to take care of them first because if people are hungry,
then socializing, learning, or working,
won't be their main priority. Slowing progress
at this stage,
the people who understand how to take care of the land would be extremely
valuable. They could teach others how to grow and harvest food.
These community members would likely be the farmers and the other households
would get rations. And there could be hunters in the crew.
There should be lots of meat options because animal life would be flourishing
around the world. Without 7.8 billion humans,
animals would be free to roam wherever they wanted.
This would also do wonders for our planet.
The atmospheric greenhouse gas emissions would eventually level out and plant
life would flourish. Again.
The earth would finally recover after the centuries of stress due to so many
humans. Okay?
Now that our food is taken care of what about love and belonging?
We are social beings and we need relationships.
This includes acceptance that a group,
family love and intimacy.
If we don't meet these needs, people could become unhappy and even bored.
How would we divide the work in our smaller pool of humans?
It could be easier to accept each other as equals,
as we're all in this global village together,
we could develop this society with greater equality and balance between the
genders or we could revert to more traditional rules for men and women
with women of childbearing years forced to have multiple pregnancy similar to
the Handmaid's tale. Well,
everything seemed to be going okay until that point still with
not too many people to choose from things like love and attraction,
wouldn't necessarily dictate who you get intimate with.
And those creepy arrangements could be a thing,
but if you're a fertile man or woman,
you might be treated better because you're responsible for increasing the
population. As we start to repopulate the planet,
there would be a need for doctors and medical professionals,
builders and construction workers would also be helpful.
Teachers would be necessary,
but people would likely start doing internships to learn in such a dramatically
different society. If someone wanted to be a doctor,
they could shadow the doctors for several years and learn from experience rather
than in a school jobs in this new society may no longer
have any cash value.
And we could see ourselves going into an exchange economy.
Something like I'll help you build your home. If you teach my kids to read,
going back to a cash based society may take some time and with
no global infrastructure to rely upon for a supply chain, barter and trade,
make sense. At least in the short term,
a 1000 person community wouldn't guarantee a stable population
we'd need to work together to overcome the challenges of living without a modern
society.
The biggest problem would be another disaster happening and wiping
out many of this already small population,
even a sickness could kill many people and leave the community vulnerable.
And what would happen if all humans suddenly disappeared from earth?
Well, that's a story for another. What if.